because I got used and I got tricked
into being told that I was loved
and I haven't played yeah JoJo siwa's
not holding back about her breakup with
Avery Cyrus funny how that works out the
two recently parted ways after three
months of dating and seems like this was
anything but a clean break JoJo's mom
jessalyn shares this moment to her
Instagram story where an emotional JoJo
sounds off why are you mad why are you
mad because I got used
for what reviews
that's a clown and I got tricked into
being told that I was loved
and they have played the candid remarks
come just a few days after Avery
confirmed their split on Tick Tock after
I got my dramatic running into the beach
videos I made my way to the swim up bar
responding to fans in the comment of
this video of her and JoJo on a cruise
Avery explains quote we decided that we
are better off as friends she adds quote
we are both so young and still just
trying to figure our stuff out and the
reason fans were curious in the first
place Sims from this moment in the same
post this is my I'm sorry for breaking
up Jojo and Avery first sparked dating
rumors back in August later making the
romance red carpet official and fast
forward to December fans are scratching
their heads on how the exes ended up
here why are you mad why are you mad
because I got used
for what reviews
and for clown and I got tricked into
being told that I was loved
and I have [ __ ] played meanwhile
JoJo's taking her fans for a different
kind of ride a stroll down memory lane
she reunited with Dan's mom's co-star
Nia Sue to recreate the show's iconic
boss lady dance
[Music]
the dance went viral on Tick Tock
earlier this year it's like a full
circle moment and fellow Abby Lee Dance
Company Alum Maddie Ziegler told E.T she
was thrilled the routines having a
moment to see like girls being like if
you didn't know this dance when you were
younger then like where were you and I'm
like I didn't know that many people even
like learned the boss ladies dance and
it's it's honestly it's the cutest thing
ever it warms my heart it's it's really
cool
[Music]